كل حال سالنا الناس في الاردن هل جمال
المراه يؤثر على سلطتها في المنزل
[موسيقى]
مش بالظاهر في انسان بتلاقيه مو حلوه
بالمره بس وجهها حلو ومنظرها حلو يعني هاي
يعني مو ضروري انها تكون بجمالها جمالها
مش الها اصلا جمالها للناس للغير اما تكون
طبيعيه وحلاوتها هيك حلوه بتجنن لا ما
باثر جمال اذا كانت جميله وما الها شخصيه
او ما الها مش صاحب قياده بالبيت ما بياثر
عليها المهم انها تكون صاحبه قياده صاحبه
شخصيه صاحبه كلمه صاحبه اداره الاداره هي
اللي بتاثر عليها بالبيت بالشخصيه مو جمال
شو الجمال يعني الحيط بيضاء بتقدر الواحده
تروح تعمل ميك اب بتقدر تروح تعمل عمليات
تجميل تغير بشكلها لكن المهم مخها اخلاها
يعني انسجامها مع جوزها مع اولادها في
البيت الاداره هذا المهم مش المهم الجمال
لا طبعا لانه بالنهايه الجمال بتغير هي
اسلوبها وطري بتمشي اسلوبها بالبيت هذا هو
اللي بيفرق مش الجمال الجمال بروح وبيجي
وبيتغير
[موسيقى]
طبعا ما باثر على سلطتها بالبيت لانه
الاساس ثقافتها فهمها شخصيتها بالبيت
ادارتها لبيتها مش الجمال في النهايه
الجمال الداخلي مش الخارجي هو المهم لا ما
دخل هلا لانه بالاخر واحد برجع له شخصيته
كيف بيتعامل مع الناس كيف
كلمته مسموعه ولا لا يعني الجمال ما له
دخل هاد اشي وهاد اشي ما له دخل للسلطه او
لا